[Music]
people walking on this world of ours
now I found
I think about the
I think somebody up above had us
exchanging glances I mean what are the
chances
[Music]
the victims of the improper screenings
all had the same views and
[Music]
turns out when he said that well III
and the lady in charge of it all
happened plead the fifth now while
that's awful winces dance I don't think
our romances I mean what are the chances
[Music]
subject stories no one buys he can't
tell me how we met girl ain't just made
in disguise regardless how
it seems that our romancing
what are the chances it's like a band
impartial agency
with no corrupt connections please
private TAC users which were then used
to sway elections and the hard drive of
the lady at the center of the buzzing
conveniently lost all the emails from
the time in question
procesor records from a second dude as
well but it turns out there weren't any
causes our draft as well so the tried to
get some records from a third person and
full
and you know they're hard breath fresh
solo
course had a fifth person and sixth
person were focused on for help and they
finally found the document known of
their heart their hard drives pacified
and
person that dates seven people
[Music]
not suspicious at all
here at Winston's
I love you girl